what a news weekend just truly a
stunning story after story and I want to
start with this bombshell report which
claims that Donald Trump directed his
attorney Michael Cohen to lie to
Congress about the reality of the Trump
Tower Moscow project and if true we're
now talking about felony obstruction of
justice and possible witness tampering
this is one of the things that brought
down Richard Nixon in the 1970s really
important not to miss that but what if
it's not true because 24 hours after the
initial report
Robert Muller spokesperson put out a
very carefully worded statement about
the story which has the right
immediately screaming fake news but the
original reporters for BuzzFeed news are
standing by the story and there is every
indication here that the spirit of the
story is 100% true so today I'm gonna
give you both sides of the full story
and we'll see where we come out the
starting point for this story is that
BuzzFeed news broke this on Friday
claiming that Donald Trump had
personally directed Michael Cohen to lie
to Congress about the Trump Tower Moscow
project and the point of that line was
to hide how involved Donald Trump really
was with the project to try to
corroborate the statements we've heard
from him in the past BuzzFeed news put
this report out they cited two federal
law enforcement officials so this is
huge because it would be evidence as I
mentioned of Donald Trump obstructing
justice for sure in the legal sense
Trump has been claiming that he had
little to do with the map
Trump Tower Moscow project that barely
anything was being done to push that
project forward the truth appears to be
that Donald Trump was actually really
involved and really wanting to push that
forward even telling Michael Cohen to go
and set a meeting with Vladimir Putin so
this would be a corroboration of
something that BuzzFeed news previously
reported on the basis of
text messages and emails so let's start
with that first of all people who
reacted by saying Oh BuzzFeed news it's
fake news BuzzFeed news is not BuzzFeed
okay this is not a fake news site it's a
news website which can get things wrong
but they source their work second
there's the idea that BuzzFeed news
would just make up having two federal
sources that they don't really have and
that would be extraordinarily stupid it
would eventually come out that BuzzFeed
News did that it would be very damaging
to them the the short-term benefit of
being able to break this story would be
far outweighed by the damage that just
making up federal sources they don't
really have would be it would be
inconceivable that they would do that
and this story comes out it appears to
be very destructive to the Trump
presidents the talk of Richard Nixon
flows freely everybody's abuzz except
then we get a statement from Robert
Moeller's spokesperson about the story
which says BuzzFeed's description of
specific statements to the special
counsels office and characterization of
documents and testimony obtained by this
office regarding Michael Cohen's
congressional testimony are not accurate
and immediately as quickly as the story
came up as a huge a damaging piece of
news for Donald Trump
the write says see the entire story was
fake news and it can all be ignored
except not quite so fast okay look at
the specific wording here the
descriptions of specific statements to
the special counsel's office not that
Cohen didn't testify to this at all but
the descriptions of specific statements
made to that office and the
characterization of documents doesn't
mean that the underlying spirit of this
is anything other than yeah Trump
instructed Cohen to lie this is a
document that interpreted narrowly as a
legal document doesn't refute the spirit
of the story
what Moeller said is that something in
the report was not totally and literally
accurate it could still be completely
true
that Donald Trump directed Michael Cohen
to lie and that's really the only part
that actually matters here and then we
have the fact that BuzzFeed news is
standing by the full scope of the story
period so let's just be objective here
we don't have to be falsely neutral
let's just be objective we can't accept
every detail of the story as 100% true
especially in light of Muller's
statement we can't count on this being
the we got'em moment but I would be
stunned if there was no factual basis to
the claim that Michael Cohen was
directed in his testimony to some degree
by Donald Trump and the most compelling
evidence for me is that both Rudy
Giuliani and a White House spokesperson
are not denying it and that's exactly
where we are going to go next one of
today's sponsors is privacy calm slash
Pakman this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping
in paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets 5 dollars towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link below